foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
this is the Ramsey show that's what
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships on Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague George
Campbell with a K and we are here for
you this hour to take your questions
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's been a great week
uh we've had some fun highlights on the
show I'm thinking of uh we took a call
from a lady whose boyfriend wanted her
to sell her car that was a wild one and
buy a truck sell his car sell her car so
he could get a truck yeah I like what
he's doing there that one and then we
talked about grocery prices
um how they're going up and then how you
can react to that the right way now it's
the eggs Ken oh yeah so it's something
new every week yeah yeah but you know
what that's got a real benefit a real
health benefit Silver Lining there on
the eggs a lot of cholesterol for you
well not for me but just eggs in general
are the big healthy thing that you think
they are oh remember the slogan when we
were growing up milk does a body good
turns out it doesn't
you know James looks like he wants to
say something my wife saw something
funny online this week that said back
when I was growing up eggs and toilet
paper were so abundant that we used to
throw them at our enemies
that's a great I love that yeah
a tree exit house can't afford to do
that in today so you know what you're
throwing money away now and you egg your
teacher's house again this was an
interesting call we took a woman whose
dad wanted her to get the prenup to
protect the family business that was an
interesting one yeah and then a really
fun segment about the five things you
need to know before filing your taxes
boy that's just a ball of Joy if anyone
can make it fun it's it's me Kenneth I
think we accomplished it you did so hey
checked all those out yeah check them
out the uh weeks podcast episodes on
your favorite podcasting platform or on
YouTube or the Ramsey Network app so
let's get to today I mean that's what's
happened so far I just have a feeling
today it's going to be really good
George we just don't know let's see
Carly starts us off in Little Rock
Arkansas Carly how can we help
I'm good how are you well I am living
the dream and and I think George is as
well
great um I
I like for something new
okay and uh you're leaning towards an
answer before we ever get into your
question what are you leaning towards
quitting for a couple months my mom told
me that I shouldn't because I get like
they paid for my tuition for school I'm
in school full-time I work full-time and
it's probably one of the better paying
jobs that I could get in my city okay so
now you've explained why mom doesn't
want you to quit the job you just laid
out mom's case what's your reason for
wanting to quit
the work environment is not like it's
very toxic there's a lot of drama
explain what is toxic give me something
specific I need a couple things
oh you broke up honest Carly speak
directly into the phone
they're never present whenever somebody
brings up an issue it's never solved
So when you say they're never present
what kind of workplace is this
um it's a telecommunications company
okay and what's happening on the floor
or in the the workspace what's what
what's happening
um so
um
I'm trying to think about it clients um
so we have like employees that think
they're
above everybody else
and management won't fix that or like
put a stop to it okay and um are these
employees doing something that is
harming you emotionally mentally or are
they doing something that is keeping you
from doing your job
keeping me from doing my job and how are
they doing that
like I'm having to do
no no no no no you do mind
and so do I and you should mind
you're putting a really positive spin on
it but if George comes to me and says
hey Ken I need you to write the first
half of my book I'm gonna go George okay
I don't mind I'm not gonna say that say
can you love to work I'm gonna go pound
sand go write your own book
come on Carly you do mind it and let me
ask you a question who says you have to
do their work them
yeah well wait a second is is your
leader their leader telling you you have
to do their work too
you broke up awesome you broke up come
on Carly stay with us
uh no no my leader my boss is not
telling me to do it okay so here's my
point
I'm not in any way diminishing the fact
that you're working in a difficult
environment
but I don't want you to just quit
the best paying job in the area if
that's in fact true
unless we have something better to go to
we don't I don't want you leaving
something I want you
moving towards something there's a big
difference
we we quit when we are quitting to
something better
out the only the only exception to that
is when it's a very dangerous
environment and it has to happen today
this is not that
agreed
agreed so
I'm okay with you quitting if I'm
quitting to something I am I am I have a
clear why
okay and you don't have a clear why here
it is difficult and I am and I'm sorry
that you've got poor leadership above
you that they are allowing this
environment I call it bad bossory on the
Ken Coleman show and it's just a
disaster and I'm sorry
but you can handle this and it starts
with you putting some boundaries up with
your co-workers by just going no
no I'm not going to do your job and I
don't care if you talk bad about me
behind my back
George what would happen Carly if you if
you set those boundaries with them what
would the response be what would the
backlash be
actually I have no idea because I've
never
19 so I
thought so you think you'd get fired if
you said hey I'm not going to do your
work for you
so like I said but it's crazy
I mean it's so hard to explain
how they do things here
okay so can you replace your income
going somewhere else
not at the moment because I don't have a
degree how much school do you have left
he said they're paying for school
um I should graduate in December of 2024
Okay so we've got uh basically another
two years
right and you're saying I can't stick
with this for two years which means we
got to go find another job that can pay
as well if not more because now we have
to cover school right if they're not
going to cover that anymore
and so you've got some homework yeah I I
gotta tell you I Carly I am the first
person to tell someone to leave if
they're in a truly toxic environment
but I tell them the same thing I'm
telling you go find something that we
have to leave too then we eject you
don't have that and by the way there's
probably going to be more problems at
the new job and so it's not all gonna
magically go away at your next employer
all right Ali I'm gonna sum this up
excuse me Carly uh Kelly's on hold but
Carla you're with us listen here's the
theme I'm gonna do what I have to do so
that later I can do what I want to do do
you hear what I'm saying I'm gonna do
what I have to do so that later I can do
what I want to do get your head down
stop trying to people please everybody
no matter if you're 19 or 49 don't do
someone else's job for them don't let
anybody bully you into doing their work
tell them to go pound sand this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
sand pound it
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today a and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman he is George Campbell we are
here for you we're talking about your
life specifically your money questions
how about your work questions well those
are tied in together and then what about
your relationship questions well those
are also all tied into
this show about you winning in those
areas of your life they all affect each
other if your work life is on fire I can
promise you your home life could be on
fire and could be affecting your
finances so George and I are here to
take your questions on those topics the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
Tucson Arizona alley is there Ali how
can we help
wow hi thanks for taking my call well
it's good to hear you what's going on
so I just have a question about in our
personal situation
um what you guys think about doing baby
step 3B step four a little bit scaled
back with 10 on investing in our 401k
and step five all simultaneously
well um three B and four I don't mind
you combining and it's kind of a Choose
Your Own Adventure at that point
depending on how much of a rush you are
to get into a house for those of you
that are listening you're going what the
heck are they talking about baby step 3B
is saving up for a down payment on a
house baby step four investing fifteen
percent and so some people they go all
right in a year or two we're gonna save
up this down payment and we're gonna
pause all investing some people say hey
I'm gonna get up to the match with my
employer on the investing side and then
the rest is going to go towards the down
payment some people say we're going to
do all 15 and slow down the down payment
saving process so you're saying you want
to do 10 investing while saving up for
the down payment
yes how long will it take you to save up
that down payment at that rate
sure um
the town and so we get mine subsidized
housing we're only paying about 425 a
month
okay um this isn't a location that we're
certain that we want to end up in but we
are here for the foreseeable future
so what's the down payment goal give me
a number
whoa this is a 10-year Journey
yeah we're just we're not home sure how
long we're going to be here in this town
and it's honestly not where we want to
end up but it's where we are for now why
300 000. that sounds like a a huge down
payment I mean it's a great goal but
yeah pause and pause your investing in
10 years that's a long time well is that
because you're planning on buying
somewhere else where it's much more
expensive
um it's because we're not sure where we
want to end up and we don't necessarily
want to buy a house here
um and we'd like to try to buy something
outright or close to it when the time
comes right so that makes sense okay
yeah if that's the case I'm going to
increase investing to 15 while saving a
little bit for college and then whatever
else we can throw for the down payment
savings let's do that
because 10 years of missing out on that
five percent investing that adds up by
the time you retire to potentially
hundreds of thousands of dollars and so
how old are you guys
um I am 28 my husband is 30. okay you've
got plenty of time since this timeline
for this house purchase is so far away I
would just go ahead and begin investing
15 and your income will increase over
those 10 years and so you'll get to that
down payment fund or even be able to pay
for something in cash and whatever you
have in 10 years when you're ready to
buy that's how much you can put down and
if you need to take on a small small
mortgage you'll pay that thing off in no
time
awesome all right thanks for the call
for the call you know she said the Mind
owned the town it took me back to one of
those westerns you know what I mean it
had that Vibe like there was a
tumbleweed what
kind of going across
that's pretty fast I didn't know that
still existed if you ever need the
mining company owns the entire town yeah
don't call Jordan Ken and I are
available for all of your westerns yeah
we do our own sound effects by the way
and um we'll travel uh let's go to
Clarksville Tennessee not too far here
from Ramsey HQ Matthew is on the line
Matthew how can we help
hey y'all it's an honor to talk to you
um so I've got a job opportunity
um
it's in a factory
um it's operating a welding robots
um not too different from what I'm doing
right now although right now I'm
Emmanuel welder just fabricating rails
um I'm looking for a little bit of
Guidance just I'm really nervous about
taking this out or not
just need some help there sure okay
let's talk about what you're nervous
about and what this what I'd want to do
is frame this in the in the form of fear
so nerves worry that's a great way of
describing fear and fear is I'm afraid
or I'm worried that something bad is
going to happen that's how I define fear
so what are you afraid of what what are
you worried about that could be bad in
your future if you take this job
I'm worried that I won't like it as much
as I like my current job and what's that
based on the fact that you're kind of
Manning a robot versus doing the welding
yourself
yes uh I think that's legitimate why do
you like welding
um it's an art it's so fun to like watch
my my work turned into
something bigger than just Spirit of
metal absolutely beautiful answer
so have you been on site for the new job
and seen how the robot works and and
what the dude is or the lady that's
running the robots doing have you seen
this not not yet I plan on doing that
later today attall boy there's our
answer I'm just gonna tell you it's that
simple
decisions like this folks if you're
listening you're going okay this is
about a guy taking a welding job no it
isn't let me tell you what this is this
is about trusting your heart as it
relates to Future opportunities
professionally
that allow you to make more money but
experience more meaning
and if he takes this job let's just say
Matthew later today you're going to see
this thing and you got to see yourself
doing this I mean you're literally
watching like a hawk
what this person is doing running this
robot and then as why as you're watching
that you're thinking about what it's
like what your heart feels like uh how
intensely focused you are when you are
doing the welding
and I'm just going to tell you right now
George his head is going to process that
information and your heart will decide
your heart will go oh my gosh staying in
there all day long pushing these three
buttons stepping back and watch this
giant piece of Machinery that's got no
Heart by the way robots have no heart
and and in case anybody was wondering
not sure why I said that with so much
Authority I'm just so sick of hearing
about all this Ai and all these robots
like we're embracing all this crap uh
you know what work is about a human
making a contribution so that's that's a
little Matthew part of this excites you
I imagine oh does this come with a with
more more money more pay of course and
more benefits yes and is this the future
of welding benefits
um
it could be although uh welding they'll
always need manual welders as well yeah
there's no lid on you so uh before I got
on the Rabbit Trail Matthew you just pay
attention and if you don't think you you
think your soul would slowly seep out of
your body doing that then I'd probably
not take it
all right
um one quick thing with that uh so
that's uh robotic welding obviously
um but it's a night shift and I was
thinking if I did that uh because it's 2
to 10 p.m
um during the night and then ask my
current employer if I could work
part-time a few days out of the week and
still be manual welding if that's a good
option if I can do that I like that
because now we got more money but you're
still engaging in the art form and you
still get something to look forward to
and I would also say that I've still I'd
still yes I'm fine with that but I'd
still want to know that you've got an
opportunity to move up Beyond robotic
welding so is it a ladder is it a step
on the ladder
yes yes that would allow you to step
into work that you really love that's
more manual
yes
well that feels like that changes my
advice the circumstances change so I'm
going to change my advice
if it is a temporary short term and I
can still keep my heart alive and still
do some of the manual welding on the
side uh for other people or for my
current employers a part-time yeah I
would do that now it's that now that's a
win-win what's the what's the pay
difference
uh it's 250 an hour more two 2.50 more
yep that adds up it does and I like the
second scenario but just a straight
leave this job for that job no I
wouldn't do that but I like the second
scenario go do that sharp young man love
that level well robotic welding
what is that I gotta go YouTube some
videos after this yeah never even heard
of such a thing hey don't move more of
your questions coming right up this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever to
bring things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 45 off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
this is where we talk about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships it's the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman joined by George
Campbell
we're here for you this hour the phone
number to jump in Triple Eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Millennials are leading the big quit in
so there was the great resignation now
there's the big quit yeah who's coming
up with these well it's it's headline
writers it's people on social media I
mean come on do I get to come up with
one at this point I feel like it's my
turn you know what why not mine is a
party every day is now a thing it's a
day National chip day National Best
Friend Day National Small Dog Day it
never it's just enough it's too much I
went on my Instagram account today at
Ken Coleman and I just looked at the
camera and said look if I hear quiet
quitting one more time I'm gonna go
headbutt an 18-wheeler I just can't do
it anymore it was like during covet it
was unprecedented oh yeah remember you
got to Pivot yeah all right boy you
really do pay attention to everything
Dave says thank you yeah yeah those are
Dave's lines you stole those There's No
Stealing here we're all we're all family
it's like the Olive Garden Ken all right
so now why are we talking about this
headline uh this is a CNBC article that
I'm pulling from because this affects
you all some of you are in this mindset
more than half of U.S workers
the number is actually 61 percent
are considering leaving their jobs in
this is from a new LinkedIn study
now it was interesting George that the
uh higher percentage or the highest
percentage of gen Z
workers are planning to call it quit so
if all of the generations gen Z
Millennials Gen X and Boomers it was gen
Z planning to call it quits
now the Millennials got beat up a lot uh
your generation about switching jobs uh
on a regular basis many Millennials this
data is probably about eight years old
but at that time Millennials were
thinking I'm going to stay about a year
on the job and then move on
um but this is what's interesting
Jen's ears
according to Karen Kimbrough the chief
Economist at LinkedIn
they're more passionate about finding a
job that aligns with their personal
values
and they're confident that switching
jobs will help them get there
so the main reasons that gen zeers and
Millennials are considering switching
jobs hasn't changed with higher comp
improved work-life balance opportunities
for career growth and flexible work
range it's all ranking as top priorities
so again nothing new here you could say
the same about Millennials what is
different is that there is a sizable
shift from the older gen xers and the
Boomers
to the Millennials and the gen's ears
and it is you know what
I want to do something that I connect to
um it's very personal
and I like that because that that's
helping people get in aligned with what
I'm trying to teach is that there is
purpose and work Beyond a paycheck and
this younger generation does long for a
connection uh in their work and I think
that is a good thing except that if you
make it all about well I'm only going to
work for a company that is very open
about their political views aligning
with mine that can get to a point where
you never it's like trying to find a
perfect Church good luck that church
shopping can be brutal here in Nashville
so thoughts on that you are a millennial
well there's a I think there's been a
cultural shift you see my parents
generation my grandparents generation it
was it was survival it was get an
education so you can get a good stable
job so you can get a pension and things
have shifted we are now in a society
that wants to thrive and so they're
going I actually want to enjoy the work
I do because I saw my parents go to work
for that paycheck and they hated that
job yeah and so they're going oh we
don't have to do that and so I like this
mentality of let me go find that thing
what I don't like is the anti-work group
or saying I don't think we should have
to work at all as a society this is
terrible I love it when they go this
ain't it let me go figure out what is
now the only risk here and this is why
we highlight this so if you're a gen Zer
a parent of a gen Zer understand these
people are just looking up they're
paying attention to the environment
and since the middle or let's call it
third quarter of 2020 when this thing
called the Great resignation happen if
you don't know what that is don't worry
about it
but we've had
four plus million people each month for
18 consecutive months this is latest job
numbers out of November of 2022. folks
that is a staggering amount of people
that are quitting their jobs so for
those of you that are as old as me or
older you understand what musical chairs
was a fun game that George has no idea
what it is so that's what the job market
looks like and these young people are
looking up and they're going hey I see
my friend move over here and they got an
eight percent bump or a 12 bump or
whatever and so now it's just like okay
now we're just going until the Music
Stops the question is when does the
music stop
and with a recession looming this year
how bad it is I don't know I tend to be
less alarmist I don't think it's going
to be big and bad but we'll see and so
the point here is is that our money
principles what we teach here
is that hey you know what sometimes it's
okay to stay
because moving for a bigger paycheck may
come back to bite you if it's an awful
environment or you're actually not
qualified to do the job or they lied to
you and now all of a sudden you're in a
situation where oh I may have to make
another move and I'm putting my
financial stability at risk there's no
reason for that
and so that's why budgeting the baby
steps can get you some more patience oh
yeah having some Financial Foundation it
helps you slow down and make better
decisions yeah all right now let's go
into another thing that's very
distressing for this young generation
America needs carpenters and plumbers
and more people in the trades
and employers are having a hard time
they got the need but they're having a
hard time finding them why
well the application rate for young
people seeking technical jobs like
Plumbing building electrical work George
has dropped by 49 in 2022 compared to
2020. that's only two years that's a
massive drop now let me tell you
something you're going Ken I why in the
world are you talking about plumbers and
electricians because
you want to know what makes a healthy
economy a strong Housing Industry you
can't have a strong Housing Industry if
you don't have Carpenters plumbers and
electricians
if you all going to sleep on this and
you think oh it doesn't matter you're
wrong
now these positions continue to grow the
need is there but students applying for
them is dropping here is a statement
from a spokesperson at the U.S Chamber
of Commerce for a long time our society
has not talked favorably about the
skilled trades they're right we've
instead encourage students to go to
college all of them go to four-year
institutions graduate and go into white
collar jobs now let me just throw
something out here George it's going to
feel a little negative but sometimes I
just have to tell the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
me God
remote work and hybrid work is the
biggest threat to White Collar jobs that
we've ever seen
do you know why thank you for asking
because it's not long before companies
are start to go wait a second you want
to make 120 or 150 to sit at home and
work
or work couple days a week in the office
and I can hire somebody in India for 60
to do it
I'm gonna let that sit for a second
do you think I'm this soothsayer of
negativity I'm not I'm telling you
companies are doing studies on this now
and it is going to be a wake-up call and
it might be six months around the corner
if we hit a serious recession
companies start going I'm going to
Offshore your job
now I'm not anti-remote work some people
I I make comments like oh you're a no no
I'm not I'm just telling you it is a
risk well is there a higher chance of
being laid off yeah if your remote
worker are we seeing that in the data
yes absolutely out of sight out of mind
they're going to lay you off especially
if they're trying to pressure you to
come back in again I don't want to get
off track here but but I'm just pointing
out that the trades folks we we've got
this marketing message that's been
shoved down our throats
that the only way to be successful is to
get a college degree and yet we're
seeing the date of the degrees are
becoming less and less relevant at
Building Wealth I told you it's by 2023
trend of the year and Big Time companies
are are removing the requirement for
degree and yet we've got trades jobs
where a kid can go to a trade school
right out of high school
for next to nothing and come out making
50 60 Grand do that for two or three
years keep moving up financially George
and then start their own business and
create jobs it's half of the time at a
tenth of the cost and you're making more
on the other end yes in other words it's
capitalism so you know what the real
issue is you parents out there for your
kid who doesn't want to darken the door
of a college because that's not how
they're wired why don't you get over
yourself and realize that it's about
their success not your status
get over it that'll preach foreign
er's the most important person in the
world for me when my drain is clogged it
ain't your fancy degree or your white
collar and your double-breasted suit or
let's bring those back can double rested
yeah I think it's time I might maybe the
question of the day will be brought to
you by that we'll see we'll talk about
it hey the rant's over your questions
coming up next don't move this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you win in your life
win with your money win in your work at
your workplace when in your
relationships so that you are on purpose
being the best that you can be making a
difference in this world we need you the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George Campbell again the number to jump
in triple eight eight two five five two
two five uh a lot of you are planning to
move sometime soon George you just moved
yeah recently yeah it's not a trauma I'm
kind of done with moving for a while
once you move you go let's not do that
again for a while yeah yeah but uh in
most places around the country you're
going to be facing some sky high home
prices and interest rates aren't exactly
returning to record lows but that
doesn't make owning a home impossible if
you want to buy or sell you got to make
sure you're financially ready and you've
got to have a trusted and experienced
real estate agent to walk you through it
not your family friend and I'm thinking
Uncle Larry right now who just got their
license and well he's an expert well no
he's not you need a pro you can find
that High Caliber Pro that Ramsay
trusted agent through our endorsed local
providers program we vet these folks
from all around the country
so that you know you're gonna have the
best support when you're moving wherever
you are going go to ramseysolutions.com
agent that's ramsesolutions.com agent to
find a Ramsay trusted real estate agent
today and yeah George I know evil I tell
you what I've had one bad agent and then
the rest of them are really good and
there's a difference huge and they're
also kind of marketing Pros they know
exactly how to Market this thing so you
can get top dollar that is correct so
there you go all right back to the
phones we go Minneapolis Minnesota
Thomas is there Thomas how can we help
Ken George how are you guys well we're
having a blast how are you holding up
out there
good man good so I got an interesting
one for you guys
um so I about almost a year ago now I
bought a 22 Toyota Tundra and I paid way
too much for it how much so I'm trying
to well about 83. it's a it's a I know
it gets worse is it limited it's a
limited so it was about I didn't know
too much of the time I just liked the
truck and I wanted to get it and I
rolled over negative equity from two
previous vehicles
um so it was the sticker on it was 57.
and I didn't know that because I didn't
I know I know I know
um and so the
so I'm I owe 73 left on it now
either that is in warranty so it's about
68 is what I
thought and then the best offer I've got
is from a local dealership there they
said they'd give me 53 for it
well to make it worse I put a lot of
miles on it I got about 36 000 and
Counting
but they'll still give you the 53 for it
with the current mileage
isn't that incredible I know that that's
which leads the foods is kind of a lead
up to where I'm going because Kelly Blue
Book was somewhere between like 46 and
48 I told the whole story I think they
took pity on me I don't know but I think
they're helping me out
so I don't have enough cash to cover the
negative equity and I can't I've tried
to get a personal loan and they're
saying they don't want to do it because
we did just buy a house too who's there
um uh a couple of the personal owned
people online maybe credit cards I think
they think my debt to income might be
pretty fast I'm guessing what other debt
do you have
so we just bought a house in January
and I have about 12 900 in credit cards
and then I have about 45 in student
loans
it's a private loan so I don't think
that credit bureaus know about it so I
don't know if that would affect getting
a personal loan or not
um and then my wife has about 15 in
student loans
and I think that about sums it up and
maybe with some little medical bills
here and there
and what's your household income
it says probably like 180 last year it
should be more this year okay that is
good news
so you need to save up fifteen thousand
dollars to cover the difference and then
we still need a different vehicle for
you correct you have two cars right now
right right no no we have we have one
car and I drive now that we moved up to
Minneapolis I drive about 50 to 60 000
miles a year for work which is why I'm
trying to get out of this ASAP while I
have the deal from that dealership at
that offer and then I have about seven
thousand cash I should be getting you
know a pretty good sized paycheck coming
up here next but I still need a car and
so the question is my dad is willing to
co-sign on like one of those zero
percent for 20 21 month credit cards to
pay off the difference
and then I would just pay that down as
soon as possible so the question is
should I do that or should I you're
giving me heartburn right now just
thinking about the situation Thomas
goodness we need to get Ken some Tums
yeah oh yeah yeah I've already eaten two
Tums off the mic as soon as you told me
the price can you not get a local bank
to give him the difference have you
tried going to a credit union not one of
these online situations I called it I
called a local credit union they said
that the most that they would do for
something like this is probably five
thousand
um
okay so let's say you could get 5K
you're still down 10K how quickly making
180 plus
15. it's it's 15 because I get five back
but after I pay it first does that make
sense so there's a five thousand dollar
warranty on the truck that gets refunded
once I either cancel it but I don't want
to cancel until I pay okay so let's say
you use this you six from your bank that
you have right now and we'll use the new
five that you get refunded towards a
vehicle
so if I use the six in the bank
plus you get five from the you said the
credit union will give you five that
gives you eleven now we're just down
four grand
so then we're gonna hustle to get these
next paychecks you have another five
well it's twenty thousand that I have to
write a check for and then they're gonna
mail me a check for five thousand back
in a month okay for the warranty takes
them a month to get it back to you if I
cancel right now then it just kind of
makes it tougher I think because I still
have to write the whole 20. so the
number the magic number we need is nine
thousand between the loan from the
credit union and the six you have in the
bank let's keep a thousand in there for
emergencies that puts you at a deficit
of nine thousand how quickly can you
stack up nine thousand dollars
all right pretty quick I might get it on
the next check I mean you have to
because you got to take this deal I'm
gonna beg that dealer to say hey I'm
gonna get this money to you but I need a
month to get out from under this thing
can you and have them sign some things
given your deadline for it to where he
knows you're good for it yeah because
here's my question forgive my forgive
but sometimes the most ignorant question
is the right question
so I'm gonna volunteer thank you George
here's what I'm wondering on his behalf
he's going to sell the truck to a
different dealer than he bought it from
is that correct
correct the one I bought it from said
I'd come out smelling like a rose if
they gave me that for it right but my
point is is that if you go to this
dealer today and and he buys it from me
for 53. you owe 15 that's still that you
owe that to the other dealer so they're
not asking for that right away they're
Toyota Toyota financial yeah but I mean
do you have to pay that off immediately
because you still owe it right
right so oh well I don't know this will
give me 53 if I don't give them a title
yeah you're gonna have to have a clean
title to do that I can't be alone
there's there's where my ignorance comes
in I knew it was in there somewhere yeah
but I just asked no no credit card no
zero percent no co-signing like you're
this is the same deal when you rolled in
two negative equities like we're just
making the problem worse
right but then if I but I also have to
drive I need a vehicle also so I was
thinking if I use my cash to buy like a
5 000 car I have to drive for work like
I drive people's houses all day and
there's no company vehicle I could rent
a car no yeah you might need to rent a
car you can look into turo as well yeah
and and you know you're paying 40 bucks
a day to rent something that's what I
would do and some of them you're gonna
have to look into unlimited mileage with
those otherwise you're going to get
dinged pretty hard driving over the
limits uh so you're gonna have to get
creative for a little while man but dude
you make 200 Grand we don't have to play
these games anymore
and so I'm saving up nine thousand
dollars as quickly as I can I'm working
overtime I'm delivering pizzas whatever
stuff in the next 30 days
yeah what do you got in the house you
got any expensive toys
you got an exercise bike you got
literally anything you can sell today on
Facebook golf clubs are they nice golf
clubs oh they're great man they're the
best and they're gone today
oh man you're doing it no come on you're
killing January in Minnesota right where
are you golfing you guys can't play golf
for six more months and that's okay
we're cutting up the cards we're saying
no more to negative equity we're done
with this Thomas we're doing whatever it
takes to get out from under this thing
we believe in you buddy you know what to
do
wow where there's a will there's a way
George can you in the market for some
golf clubs I tell you what I was gonna
get them for you upgrade your little
mini golf set yeah that thing's a joke
hey good hour George Campbell thanks to
the team for keeping us on the air and
thanks to you America for listening this
is your show this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
it's camel here if you love the show and
you want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we've got a Weekly Newsletter
that gives you helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving in storage Studio
this is the Ramsay show it's where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about life specifically money work and
relationships I'm your host Kim Coleman
joined by my co-host George Campbell
this hour the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we've got a bunch of new listeners
and viewers
that are joining the conversation and
we're thrilled about that if you want to
learn more about the baby steps and how
to get started in this conversation go
to ramseysolutions.com and click on the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation season of life
and need so go do that it's the get
started button at
ramsaysolutions.com all right George you
warmed up I'm ready to go I saw you were
gargling hot salt water uh during the
Americano oh it was an Americano okay so
you're ready to go oh yeah you sound
strong a voice caffeinated and irritated
let's go really yeah boy I'm very
excited to see how that plays out uh all
right let's go to devony uh who is
joining us in Myrtle Beach South
Carolina how can we help
hi I have been struggling with a budget
for what feels like forever I've used
every dollar I've listened to the books
just recently started listening to the
podcast but I still can't seem to stay
on a budget and get us out of debt well
are you in good hands today with George
camel I'm okay so tell me where where
you feel like you're failing with this
we set the budget and then we go over it
so we'll set it for let's say food and
then we go over that or we set it for
let's say entertainment and we spend it
on something else or something else
comes up okay so let's take the food
category this is an easy one to to
Grapple with so you have the food what's
your food budget every month
that you said I don't know what to said
it as that's the problem too is I have
trouble knowing what to set it at how
many months have you been doing this
we've been on and off trying to set a
budget for three years probably like
it's just never so what's the if you
look back at how much you spent last
month or the month before give me an
average are you spending 500 and you're
setting it for 250
uh well we we probably it kind of
fluctuates so let's say we spend 400 or
800 on food eating out and groceries and
all of that stuff are you guys trying to
get out of debt what's the goal here
with doing the budget yeah yeah we have
insane amounts of debt so why are we
eating out that's part of the problem
we are too lazy to cook at home
or give us some answers now yeah this is
not a budgeting issue
this is a lifestyle issue for sure we
have trouble
yeah you're not focused do you guys
really want to get out of debt or is it
just kind of an ish is it just like ah
it would be nice
no it's it's Weighing on us
so when you get in that car and you go
out to eat do you feel like a shame and
guilt afterwards where you're like man
gosh we just blew 60 bucks we could have
ate at home but we just our brains are
foggy from Warwick we didn't want to
cook that's normal right that's how I
feel after I order extra fries
been there and so we've got to adjust
our behavior and create the right habits
when it comes to budgeting so let's say
you set it for two 200 bucks and we're
not eating out that's our grocery budget
for the week now we go all right we got
to stick to that we have to track what
we're actually spending and so are you
tracking each transaction in the budget
or is it just kind of you said it yeah
go over it at the end of the month you
have some shame and then you repeat the
process
yeah the letter
well know that you are not alone and
budgeting's hard it's it's kind of fun
when you make it and it looks great on
paper and then having to stick to it is
very difficult and so I'm gonna I'm
gonna jump in here George budgeting is
not hard it's behaving within the budget
is what so on yeah we can all make the
Excel spreadsheet but then not eating
out after a long week that's the
difficult part it's the sacrifice and so
this is going to take some forward
planning it's going to take sacrifice
because right now you have a pile of
debt how much debt do you have
um not including our house with student
loans and other Consumer Debt like 214
000. 214 000. yep what's the bigger
debts in there
we've got two car payments and an RV
and then we've got like 11
000 in credit card debt what's your
household income
uh about 120. what's what's the RV worth
about 26. what do you owe on it
uh 23 I believe what about the car loans
what's the cars worth and what do you
all want them
um we owe 25 and 19 and they're both
worth about just that like I think I
might be upside down in mine all right
first things first we're going to sell
the RV today
that's a depreciating asset and at least
you're we hope you're you you're not
upside down on that one
no we're not upset we'll get rid of how
much money do you guys have in the bank
the two thousand dollars okay
if I'm you guys I'm saving up for a cash
car a beater to get around two of them
and I'm selling this the whole kit and
caboodle
you make 120 you have almost double that
in just Consumer Debt
no wonder you guys are eating out you're
stressed out to your eyeballs you can't
even think straight yeah but George I I
really I want them to I agree with your
advice but I want her to sell the RV
today let's get some momentum yes like
because that one we don't we got to
spend we got to save up some money and
replace the cars you don't have to do
Jack squat to sell the RV and then you
come away with three grand that George
will tell you what to do with three
grand what's your what are your payments
add up to servicing all that Consumer
Debt each month oh God
it's probably like twelve hundred
dollars or more so 1200 bucks to keep up
with the payments what's your take-home
pay
um it varies I'm I'm self-employed and
then my husband's a firefighter so it
depends on his way if he works overtime
or not what are you doing for work 400
it could be 2000 I'm a photographer okay
so can you step up your photography game
for a year after we sell this RV
I mean I'm so
can we charge more can we do some
specials how about do something else in
between trying to grow the photography
business let's go make some money
the great news about this is this is
solvable
getting rid of the cars in the RV is the
game changer
have you cut up the credit cards yet and
close the accounts
no I I thought I got stuck in that you
have to have your credit your credit
score so I like left them all open for
what until I I well I didn't know that
you didn't really need a credit score
which I listened to the episode the
other day okay well then today we can
cut up those cards they're not a
blessing in your life they're not a
crutch they're not for emergencies they
are keeping you broke
right so my goal for you we sell the RV
we get the income up we stick to the
budget and the way we do that is by
actually caring about the end result of
doing the budget which is to get out of
this mess and so at every turn every
time a transaction comes out of your
bank you've got to ask yourself is this
worth continuing to be in debt stressed
out not where we want to be not where we
should be you guys make six figures and
it all goes out to lenders every month
and so you've got to really find that
why Channel it and then that'll help you
go all right we're gonna be we're gonna
start meal planning we're not going out
to eat we're cutting every subscription
no more travel for the year we are gonna
batten down the hatches and get out of
debt once and for all and if you start
doing this stuff and you might need to
sell the cars once you have enough cash
to get the beaters that's going to help
you climb out of this pile and see the
light at the end of the tunnel so hang
on the line I'm gonna send you every
dollar premium which will connect to
your bank there's a paycheck planning
tool it will help you finally get
control of your money so hang on the
line Austin will give that to you to
help you on the journey thanks for the
call thank you so much you can do this
you gotta believe that you can do it but
you got to start taking action I'd list
that RV within the next hour thank you
so much for the call hey George camel
I'm Ken Coleman this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
show continues from our Ramsey Solutions
world headquarters
in the Nashville area I'm Ken Coleman
joined by George Campbell the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five eight eight
two five five two two five
well is it possible to build wealth in
this economy
we keep hearing that question and we
understand the heart of the question
there's a lot of noise out there about
inflation stubborn inflation looming
layoffs new headlines every day about
more layoffs Rising interest rates and
on and on and on the negative news goes
that's why we've decided to bring our
Building Wealth live event to more
cities
Dave Ramsey and our team will be coming
to a city near you in the spring each
Building Wealth live event has its own
unique lineup Dave Ramsey George
Campbell Rachel Cruz and Jade warshaw
will be in Indianapolis on February 16th
on February 23rd you'll see Dave Ramsey
myself Dr John deloney and Jade warshaw
in Austin Texas next we head to Salt
Lake City on April 24th where you can
see Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz George
Campbell
and Christina Ellis and then for our
last stop Dave Ramsey myself Dr John
deloney and Christina Ellis we'll wrap
up the tour in Anaheim May the second
tickets start at 49 or you can get a
four pack of tickets starting at
175 dollars bring your friends it's
gonna be a lot of fun go to
ramseysolutions.com events that's
ramseysolutions.com events to revert to
reserve your seats today so George as I
look here we are um I'm gonna miss you
on the road Ken we're just two ships
passing in the night it looks like our
on-road tension has finally caught up
with us they've decided to separate us I
thought it was because we're too
powerful together on the road I think
it's because they're worried about the
root beer float taking over I agree
we're such a popular combo here uh on
the show that we were called a root beer
float and they're like well we don't
want to distract from Dave being out
there I mean they're the star of the
show I mean if we're the root beer float
Dave's the steak he's the bell of the
ball Ken always a bridesmaid never a
bride you know I wouldn't call him that
I like the steak analogy a little bit
better it feels more appropriate he's
not listening it's fine that is true
I'll tell you who is listening though
it's Sarah
Sarah in Cincinnati sounds like a
rom-com I love that alliteration yeah
there you go let's go to Sarah now Sarah
how can we help
hi guys thanks for taking my call you
bet
um so I had a quick question I am a
photographer another photographer you
guys just talked to one but yeah
um I just got a small inheritance to my
trust to my grandma after she passed
away and I wanted to know I need new
equipment for my business just a small
amount not a lot and the amount of money
that I'm getting isn't huge but I was
wondering what to do with the amount
that's left over after we're still
paying off our debts and we pay off
about 70 000 good for you and we've got
thank you and we've got about 90 left I
believe just a little over 90 left to
pay off
um and so how much is the inheritance
um it's before taxes it's like a little
over twelve thousand dollars so after
taxes it would be close to like nine or
yeah like are you sure are you sure
there's taxes on it
um when we went and met with the um
person who takes care of her trust with
Edward Jones they um told us that there
was like 25 or 22 because of our tax
bracket I guess okay just wanted to
verify because a lot of the time
inheritance isn't taxed for the person
who's receiving it but if you got that
information from a professional I would
trust them yeah okay yeah so you think
it'll be closer to nine thousand
yeah so after tax and everything it'd be
just a little bit either North or South
it just depends I'm not exactly sure the
exact amount but right around that 9 000
Mark how much does the photography
equipment cost that you feel like you
need
I just need a camera so it would be
somewhere close to about twenty five
hundred dollars and the rest would be
just like free
and how much are you making from this
photography business
about 75 000 after taxes and everything
way to go it's awesome and what's your
household income if you include your
spouse
um I think about 210
000 total wonderful
well
I I'm in the boat of wanting to use this
money to pay down the debt and we
upgrade the camera equipment through
your business income through kind of
fresh new income
um either way you're going to be using
the cash but I'm just wondering it would
feel different if you're investing in
new equipment through cash flow from the
business
how much money do you guys have in the
bank
um we've got our so since we're just
doing our though we're in baby stuff
three or two because we're paying off
all of our debt we've got the thousand
dollar emergency fund okay so then
everything else is just going towards
like that what kind of debt's the 90
that's remaining
um student loans uh student loans I have
one car payment and the rest is
um
okay
what's left on the car loan
uh like like nine thousand and what's
the car worth
uh
6027 oh
that's pretty tempting I think I'm
paying now George that's what I'm
thinking she was like I was hoping he
wouldn't go there I mean I'm just
looking at the Hard Math on the thing I
mean you're gonna net 17. you'll get a
car for seven now you've got ten
thousand that magically appeared and I
would feel a whole lot better using that
money to purchase the new equipment the
rest going towards the debt to put a
little bit of skin in the game
because right now it doesn't feel like
the you guys are you're you're on the
plan for sure but it's easy to get a
little bit comfortable this money you
know from Grandma which what a beautiful
Legacy to leave
um yeah would I don't know I don't know
Grandma I don't know how she would have
wanted you to use it I think it's
beautiful either way for using it to
grow your business using it to pay down
debt uh those are both great things but
I still would want some sacrifice to
feel like I earned this camera purchase
okay
but either way you're going to get there
it's not a lot of money at the end of
the day uh and see if you can get the
camera used are you buying a new camera
that was my thing as I was definitely
going to get it used because it's it's
not something that I need to get brand
new okay yeah I might just pause and not
rush into the camera purchase and go let
me wait let me find a deal on Facebook
Marketplace Craigslist my photographer
community in Cincinnati there's people
unloading gear left and right I'm I'm
curious what's the I want to make sure
you caught the momentum there where
George George is very very nice I think
you gotta sell the car because it allows
you to fast forward so much what's the
on your debt snowball what's the
smallest amount what is it a credit card
what's the amount it's a credit card
almost like six thousand I'm taking this
what's the interest rate on that card
um
23 yeah and where's the Thomas Ken I'm
Gonna Fill in while George wipes it he
just threw up in his mouth and he's wipe
his mouth off uh my question is what is
the payment on that that credit card for
nine well right now well without the
extra payment we're putting on
. I'm taking grandmother's money
and I'm gonna pay off that credit card
now that you know what to do I know
where I was going that's okay that what
I would do is I'd take the money from
Grandmother pay off the next snowball
which is nine thousand on a credit card
you know what to do you've done it so
far you roll that money into the next
thing I would sell the car
like George said that's 26 get a 10 000
car that's okay
and now now we're sitting there with
more money to put on the next credit
card I mean you're just motoring here
this is like advancing the momentum is
what I would do
and now making 210 having to pay off you
know 70 grand we're going oh we got this
thing in the next year like we can see
the light at the end of the tunnel and
that's the whole goal is how do we speed
this up because this is not fun we can
all admit that getting into the mess was
kind of fun along the way getting all
the stuff but now we're looking back at
it with regret and so I want to speed up
this process so you guys can focus on
the future and building for that instead
of paying for the past so that's the
spirit of all this it's not because I
don't want Sarah to have nice things
it's because I see this sweet gift from
Grandma as a little fast forward chip in
the debt snowball more than I do a oh
shiny new camera look at that yeah I
agree and the camera will get there
you're already crushing it with the
photography business do an extra few
sessions and use that money towards the
camera and George's she does what we
said sells the car takes the money from
grandmother and just fast forwards the
whole process what is the feeling and
one word that you get from that kind of
a big ax I'm gonna go with Elation
Elation Joy I like that I mean that's
one
swing at that big old tree there I love
it thank you so much for the call Sarah
you've got this don't move more Ramsey
show coming right up
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
David is up in Columbus Ohio David how
can we help
hello hello
what's going on
well my wife and I went to the Financial
Peace University DVD set last year and
it helped us to pay off quite a large
amount of debt from our credit cards and
a personal loan that I had and um we've
worked ourselves down to two deaths but
we seem to be stuck in a revolving door
of the baby steps the past six months
and
um and kind of looking for guidance on
where to go from here okay what's this
revolving door have you had some
emergencies
year we built up our emergency fund
we've got three vehicles one of them I
owe on the other two we own outright the
two that we do own on have some higher
miles so every time we build up the fund
they need maintenance or the house needs
maintenance
um we build up our six months uh
essentially savings and unfortunately
last year we had an unexpected need to
put a roof on the house so that took a
big chunk out of that fund as well so
we're kind of looking where to get it
from here I'd like to put more on my
401k
how much are you putting now
uh I was putting 15 in uh last year I
cut it back to six percent to help pay
off the excess debt and I'm wanting to
take that back to 15. but I'm torn as to
whether to put more into 401k or to pay
off the car loan that I currently have
I'm confused as to which Financial Peace
University you went through David you're
doing 17 things at once yes that's
that's our our downfall we seem to take
on way too much at once okay so how
about this what if for six months you
tried the plan as is and you went all in
which means we're not investing we're
taking our savings down to a thousand
dollars and we're putting every single
ounce of energy and money towards our
Consumer Debt
would you would you take that challenge
absolutely and I tell you that because I
have such confidence in you and I've
seen thousands of people who go all in
actually accomplish it and I've also
talked to hundreds more on the phones
who go hey I don't know why I'm not
making the progress I should be and also
I'm not following the baby steps as is
and so it's not to be fundamentalist
it's just to go when you focus all of
your energy and intensity on one thing
at a time you make progress that's all
it is so how much do you have left in
Consumer Debt
we owe a hundred thousand dollar house
and we owe 13 Ohio 13 000 on my car so
we're just 13 away from this thing being
done in baby step two
correct what's the car worth
uh it books for right number 14 however
the offers I've gotten from the dealer
I've tried to sell back to them um
they're not winning the budge off of 10.
well forget the dealers let's go private
party let's do our research online and
see if there's any online companies that
would buy it for more and uh go from
there because this clears the deck for
you to be able to start saving up that
fully funded emergency fund and you have
three cars do you need can you survive
on with two
uh yeah we're exploring the option of
selling our truck we own an outright so
that would be you know sixty five
hundred to seven thousand dollars we
could pocket
okay and I I don't want to miss David I
want you to miss what George said you're
kind of like yeah don't sell the car to
the dealer they're never going to give
you what you can get private parties
it's not even close
yeah I I tried to sell a private party
last month and unfortunately you know a
lot of Tire kickers not a whole lot of
interest and they seem to offer about
the same as where'd you listed where'd
you post it
explaining this on Craigslist local ads
Facebook just a couple places well are
you offering are you selling it for what
it would it really could command via
Blue Book
oh yeah the new books uh listed it for
13.9 I had them priced just under 14.
um I even had a couple offers out you
know that someone was willing to do 13.5
essentially that would dissolve the loan
and I'd pocket 400 and I could wash my
hands of it and continue on the phone
why didn't you do that
uh the best offer I could get was around
10. oh you weren't actually getting
those Oh I thought you said yeah yeah
that's the downside what's your
household income David
uh we bring in we gross about 100 a year
okay so let's say we even didn't sell
the car how quickly do you think this
thing's getting paid off if we brought
investing down to zero and we want full
focus on getting rid of this car loan
um
I know without touching the investing we
calculated we could potentially be paid
off by August uh without the investing
I'm thinking 90 days max
you guys are bringing you know I mean
you're bringing home what 7K a month
um a little bit under that
so 13 let's say we could divide that in
three right
that's going to be 4 300 bucks a month
so the question now becomes how do we
find 4 300 worth of margin to throw at
this debt which means we're pausing
investing which means we're not eating
out which means we're hatching you know
getting the the budget dialed in could
you come up with four grand a month to
throw out this car alone
absolutely
and so now 90 days from now we're at
baby step three and so we're out of this
vicious cycle you've been experiencing
and if there was another emergency we
would just pause the baby steps and
start saving up with those future
paychecks
okay
but you got to go all in for this to
work David and so I want you to call us
back as you go all in on this and let us
know if anything has changed for you
because I think it will yeah good advice
there thanks again for the call let's go
to Glenn in Chicago Glenn how can we
help
gentlemen my wife and I are uh trying to
figure out if we're on baby step 3B or
baby step four
um we've paid off a lot of debt and uh
we have our emergency fund in place
um
but because we have uh four kids and
we're thinking about college uh but we
also don't own a home yet we're just
trying to figure out what the priority
now needs to be
so you said you've paid off a lot of
debt is the debt gone completely
yes sir that's correct everything
awesome and you've got a fully funded
emergency fund how much do you have in
the bank for that
fifteen thousand wonderful so you're
wondering should we focus on 3B with a
down payment or do we go ahead and start
investing that 15 and then what about
college is that the kind of conundrum is
what speed to do all of these
that's that's exactly right you got it
what how old are you two
my wife is 36 and I am 31. okay is there
a rush to get into a home
you got four kids and you're renting is
the is there enough space are you guys
good there could you rent for a few more
years yes we could I think we could rent
for another three years I'm we're both
content with that
great and then have you been investing
at all previously or is this all new
we've been setting aside 150 every month
into a Roth uh for the last year
um other than that we've been setting
aside uh we've got about 30 grand now
for the house in addition to the
emergency fund in a brokerage account so
right we are investing uh but really the
150 is the retirement investment the the
rest of the savings we have is going
into the like I said a brokerage for for
the house okay if I'm in your shoes if
you're doing The Brokerage you want to
have a longer term time frame and
mindset so this is a three plus decision
for the home
and so if that's the case I would start
investing 15 I would throw a little bit
into you know a 529 or an Esa for each
of those kids and then anything
remaining is going to go towards the
down payment to keep you know saving up
for that
and then whatever money you have at the
end of those three years or four years
that will help us decide how much house
we can afford and where we're going to
live and all those decisions
okay so for now you you think it would
be best to start 15 into retirement
yes at your your ages with uh you know
you haven't saved a whole lot I want the
power of compound interest working for
you you guys have done the hard work of
getting out of debt getting the
emergency fund in place now let's start
building for the future so that the kids
don't have to cover you guys in
retirement
because there's 100 chance you'll retire
there's a 50 50 chance the kids go to
college and graduate and so I want to
make sure we're at least investing at 15
we'll get the down payment when we get
there and let's put a little bit for
college to help that money grow thanks
for the call yeah got this Glenn good
advice George I'm trying to keep up Ken
uh you're doing more than keeping up you
uh you get yourself a little protein bar
it's all the caffeine a little protein
all the caffeine is starting to make you
crash a little protein during this break
he'll be ready folks and I've always got
the juice so don't worry about me this
is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell we're
taking your calls to shower triple eight
eight two five five two two five
uh studies show George that most people
abandon their New Year's resolutions by
February
are you aware of that's a shame how are
you doing on yours did you have any at
all you know I just said a few I usually
go overboard and I went a little more
focused this year what was your focus
and I'm on track uh trying to get the
habit of reading and writing those are
the big ones
you like you skipped Elementary School
well reading more books oh and then a
habit of writing more regularly and are
you staying with it mostly all right
good well the truth is it's too early in
the year to get discouraged about
finding meaningful work purpose in the
workplace
purpose period you don't have to resort
to quiet quitting because
you want to make a change but don't know
where to start you were designed you
were created to fill a unique role in
and through your work that means you
were needed and you must do it somebody
out there needs you to be the best
version of you that's why I do the Ken
Coleman show here on the Ramsey Network
and it's why I created the get clear
career assessment so that you can see
how you are uniquely made to contribute
in other words your talent what you do
best your passion what work you enjoy
and then your mission what results
motivate you to do your best work
it's only going to take about 15 minutes
to answer some specific questions that's
going to give you a custom report that
describes you in the way I just laid out
and it makes some suggestions to you but
more importantly it allows you to have
maybe for the first time in your life
awareness
that will lead to tremendous confidence
and courage
to be who you're supposed to be and and
the result of that George is more income
and more impact More Money More meaning
you can get the get clear assessment
today at ramseysolutions.com
get clear ramseysolutions.com get clear
and if you need more uh Direction even
after results call me on the Ken Coleman
show helping a lot of people and this is
a game changer for those of you who feel
stuck so go check it out all right let's
get to the phones Ruth joins us in Los
Angeles California Ruth how can we help
hi
um I'm calling because I'm at a life
stage where I've come through a lot of
transition my my husband passed away uh
three years ago
and
um what happened over the course of time
is that he passed away and in the course
I I took on our properties and that sort
of thing so I
inherited wealth or took over the family
business that part of it
and um
I lost a lot oh actually like all family
friends and I've had family try to sue
me for part of his estate and I'm in a
place where I just need new friends and
I'm looking for people that have wealth
and are interested in using it to reach
out and make an impact and help others
but I don't know where to go for that
sort of thing wow
well first of all you've been through a
lot and yeah that's tough and uh you do
need those people and and you need
friends you have you did I hear you say
you lost your friends
oh yeah well yeah I mean I lost my best
friend she died the year before my
husband died so but also what happened
is all of a sudden friends expected me
to be
give them money or make things throw
them parties that sort of thing it got
it got weird yeah because I saw you come
into a lot of wealth and then they got
real attached
uh yeah and so I mean I literally had to
cut
basically everybody out
well I'm sorry you've been through that
and and I I will tell you though I think
you do know where these people are you
know so you're in the Los Angeles area
um you are
uh still running the company I'm
guessing
um yeah yeah I mean you I don't it
pretty much you know it pretty much runs
itself I'm basically retired I don't
really need to do very much
before my husband passed as well so
first thing I want you doing is I have
something I'm sorry I just want you
here's what I want you to do I want you
to start joining some social activities
where you know quite frankly let's just
be really honest where other wealthy
women are going to be
because now now they don't need you for
anything
and you're going to find some
like-minded souls and people who
understand you and they're not you know
they're just friends with you they just
want to play tennis with you or they
want to play bunker or they don't want
anything they don't want anything other
than just it's a social thing so I mean
this is as simple as you know local
country clubs and and Social Clubs and
like you got to get out and meet people
and the only way to meet people is to
get in those places where those people
are congregating and there's nothing
wrong with that you know the old phrase
birds of a feather flock together well
you know where those people are flocking
yes or no
uh why would I be calling you Russell
I think you're calling for I think
you're calling for ideas which I'm
giving you ideas but you know where
those people are where where in the Los
Angeles area do you live give me give me
the uh the neighborhood or the the area
of Los Angeles
it's like Manhattan Beach Manhattan
Beach okay great lovely area okay so are
there country clubs in in the Manhattan
Beach area
um yeah okay so that's a that's a big
dollar thing I know hold on we're
brainstorming all right so it's not a
country club you live in a neighborhood
where it's right it's got an HOA
a little bit with HOA yeah yeah so is
there's Facebook groups probably in your
community there's probably multiple for
different social groups I mean I'm in a
small neighborhood and we've got a ton
of them and so I would start connecting
go to the HOA meetings just to meet
people in the neighborhood because
likely they are on the same level of
wealth in a in a general way as you and
then you start joining those Facebook
groups and find figure out what hobbies
you want to connect with people over or
do you have things that you like to do
for fun
yeah I mean just like what you guys were
saying in the break I mean I love
reading I love writing I like hiking and
that sort of thing I have a disabled
family member that lives with me my son
and that limits the amount of time I
have free to to go out engage yeah so I
I do have a but yeah
I I still even in the neighborhood I run
into situations where people are asking
a lot of financial questions and that is
that that's uncomfortable you mean like
they're asking you for money
no they're asking you how much I sold my
house for they're asking me how much the
repairs on my house I mean I don't
normally
I don't know I don't expect to be having
those kind of conversations with people
that are friends it would be more like
you know how's your mom or how was your
trip your vacation or that sort of thing
um well again so I mean I appreciate
George jumping in and I appreciate what
you're saying but you you do know where
wealthy people are spending time you do
you simply do I don't know Manhattan
Beach like you know Manhattan Beach but
you know in surrounding areas I mean you
you've got more Hobbies than just
reading and writing now you are limited
and I think this is part of the problem
or I should say challenge because of
your son I mean that's a challenge for
you you just don't have a ton of time so
you've got to make the most of that time
and so whether it be book clubs in
certain areas but I mean you know where
are wealthy people people that are
successful that again aren't clingy and
aren't looking for anything from you
other than just the enjoyment of
relationship and a shared hobby or
shared interest that's what you've got
to do you make a list of your interests
and where are people hanging out and
you're in a very wealthy area so it's
not going to be hard to run into those
people but it is it is going to be some
intentionality like George said uh on
certain maybe groups and and talking
around the neighborhood and then you
know listen it depends on how much of
this the rest of your life this this
wants to be a big deal you've got a lot
of money if you need to move to a better
area you know I mean this is the stuff
life is made of you can't do this alone
you don't want to be alone and you need
this and so you need to make moves to
put yourself around those people
it's just you deciding it's time and
here's a challenge Ruth what if you
started the book club and you posted in
your neighborhood Facebook group and
said hey I'm going to have people over
once a week here's what we're doing let
me know if you want to join that happens
all the time and it's a great way when
you're the initiator amazing things
happen yeah I love that idea
okay so just put yourself out there it's
gonna be a little scary it's you know as
you get older like less likely to want
to put yourself out there but uh you
know as you just go grocery shopping or
where you're out and about make
conversation with people yeah I mean
where are women exercising or doing
things in the Manhattan you're just
looking for Affinity groups and
something that you're interested in and
that's just paying attention to what's
out there by the way George you ever
been to Manhattan Beach no I want to go
now though absolutely lovely little area
the street kind of just goes down into
the pier let's go little buddy buddy uh
is that what we're doing all right well
we'll book it during the commercial
break don't move more of the Ramsey show
coming up
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
this is the Ramsey Show it's where
America is hanging out to have a
conversation specifically about your
money life your work life and your
relationship life the phone number to
join in is triple eight eight two five
five two two five I'm Ken Coleman George
Campbell joins me this hour again the
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're gonna
start this hour off with Cara in Houston
Texas Cara how can we help
hi
um I have a 401k and I wanted to roll it
over to a Roth IRA but I needed to take
some money out so I'm wondering is it
best to do a withdrawal now and then
roll it over or roll it over and then
try to take a withdrawal I just wouldn't
take a withdrawal at all how old are you
from an old employer of 10 years ago so
I completely forgot about this so this
old 401K you've had sitting around and
you're at retirement age now and you can
withdraw from this with no penalties is
it a traditional 401k
yes
I would uh go through with the
withdrawal the rollover direct rollover
to a traditional IRA and then use that
money
okay that's short and sweet that's all I
needed to know absolutely all right how
about that that was the easiest call of
the day Ken there you go thanks for the
win Carol way to go Cara Jennifer is now
up in St Petersburg Florida Jennifer how
can we help
uh hi hi
um so I'm just gonna
um I need assistance to figure stuff out
because my my husband may possibly be
laid off of work and we have a home that
we need to pay for that we just recently
purchased and we don't really have major
bills but I I have a job a side job and
I'm going into like a third job uh so
it's just kind of like you know how can
we prepare in case that was to happen
okay so what do we know what do we know
not what we think and what we feel right
now we want to focus on what we know
about the possibility of him being laid
off what what is he hearing what is it
new management on board now in the
company and there's like this one major
project that they've had him working on
and once that project is done
um previously they had talked about you
know converting diet particular office
space into something that has nothing to
do with what he does now okay so when
does he anticipate that the project that
he's working on will be finished in
about a month and a half all right so we
start there all right so worst case
scenario is in a month and a half they
lay him off
all right so in that month and a half
time starting today tonight
if it's me this is what I would do if I
were your husband I'd be reaching out to
people that I know in his industry uh
people that may know somebody in other
companies that uh hire people to do what
he does so we're just looking you know
St Petersburg Florida big area
pretty pretty good job market is my
guess and so I'd be shaking the tree
like he's looking he's applying I mean
he he can start that process now he
doesn't have to take it he can start
interviewing you know the thing is that
he's already like out of his max like
he's actually getting over overpaid for
what he actually does you know in
anywhere else what does that have to do
with what I told you though what does
that have to do with the fact that it's
that that he's still got to be looking
for something we need a plan we need a
backup plan yeah so you're saying worst
case there's a slight reduction in
income if he goes to a different company
so we'll that'll adjust our budget so
let's look at the numbers here are you
guys okay financially
um for the most part yes do you have day
um just like the the house and we don't
have car we we don't have car depth um
credit cards we do have
um I have a like two credit cards um not
to that nothing too crazy maximum maybe
like 3 000. are you carrying a balance
you have credit card debt are you
carrying yes how much
like two two thousand change you know I
just recently got the credit card so of
course during the holiday you know well
the best thing you can do when this is
just kind of the warning sign is to cut
them up because if you have a reduction
income the last thing you need is
payments to lenders and so I would get
rid of these cards pay them off do you
have money in the bank right now not
really I tried starting like a savings
account I've always been very bad about
financials like very I've always like
counted pennies because I've always been
for the most part a single mom so
obviously now it's different he actually
on the other hand he's very good with
finances and savings and you know
numbers he's like a numbers man okay so
hold on hold on a second let's slow down
for a minute and I appreciate we're
asking about your money but you called
to say what are we gonna do if he gets
laid off the point is is number one
George will help you need to get
discipled money we're going to give you
some resources so that you two get on
the same page I'm glad he's good with
money you need to let him lead in that
way let him model for it say hey I'm in
okay I want to do the things the way
that you do things all right that's a
start but the reality is is that he
makes x amount of dollars how much does
he make
close to 30. 30 000 and what does he do
no no close well close to thirty dollars
the hour oh thirty dollars an hour so
we'll call that about 60 Grand that's a
year yeah so what does he do
um
do I really have to share that no but
but you don't have to I was just simply
trying to say I said to you my first
thing was he needs to start looking for
jobs looking for work that he does now
that he's got some actual experience in
and some skill your your first response
was well he already makes more than he
would anywhere else and that's not the
mindset I mean he needs to be looking
right now he doesn't want to not have an
exit strategy you know we go on
airplanes they tell us in case of a
water landing or a crash or whatever we
gotta exit here exit here exit here
that's what I'm trying to explain to you
he needs he's got a month and a half
lead time in a worst case scenario he
may not get laid off at all but he's got
a month and a half and so I give it back
to George to help you on the money stuff
but I want to make sure you're going
back to him going hey you start looking
out I can start looking for you with you
we're looking for opportunities that may
be available now start the interviewing
process and then if he gets a couple of
job offers if they're good he can go
back to these guys and go hey guys I got
a couple offers New Management do you
want me here I mean he's got some
leverage so let's go find some
opportunities an exit strategy
okay so that's the career side Jennifer
the financial side the best thing you
can do in case this happens and in case
any emergency happens is having no debt
and a bunch of cash in the bank and so
that is your A1 over the next 45 days is
to get rid of all Consumer Debt and
start saving up money and savings which
means we're not going to go out to eat
we're not going to go on our shopping
sprees to Target or whatever your
favorite places we are getting really
serious right now we're in a storm okay
and so how much debt do you have outside
of those two credit you said you have 2
000 in credit card debt anything else
yeah uh well that's that's my credit
card
um you know the other credit card that
we mostly pay like some of the bills
um which is about anywhere between you
said he's good with money if he's
racking up credit card debt he ain't
good with money and so let's cut up
these cards and by the way it's our
money it's our credit cards let's get
our plan together it's not he's good and
I'm bad and we're just doing our own
thing we're gonna send you one year of
Financial Peace University so that you
guys can get on the same page create
shared values goals common language and
you will get through this layoff if you
do what Ken said and jump to a different
career
time to get serious
the best way to do that is to be safe
and have peace with your money this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
welcome back America if you joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by George camel
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number it's time for our
question of the day brought to you by
laminators
keeping your sensitive documents
protected since 1958 Gotta Love a
laminator yeah I love you ever used one
here in the break room as a matter of
fact yeah nothing gives me more joy the
documents that I go to often on the Ken
Coleman show are in fact laminated love
it our question comes from Brandy in
Colorado she says I'm 42 and a single
mom of a 16 year old I had to withdraw
all of my retirement to help cover
unexpected medical expenses I'm a renter
no retirement savings now and live
paycheck to paycheck I just received two
job offers and I don't know what to pick
option one full-time working for the
federal government with awesome
retirement and benefits with an annual
salary fifty seven thousand option two
full-time corporate job with an annual
salary of a hundred thousand and a 401K
with a match of three percent should I
accept the higher paying job to help me
pay off the 10K in credit card 20K car
and 2 000 monthly rent in Colorado or
should I choose the federal government
job with stability and good retirement
I would like to be debt free in three
years so I can move to another state
where cost of living is more reasonable
and I can purchase a condo or town home
for myself well Brandi thank you for the
easiest question of the day that I've
ever had to answer it's absolutely
number two and it's not even close I
think the word here in your two
questions it's got you hung up on this
because this is so obvious to George and
I to take the corporate job where you're
making almost double and that doesn't
even include potential raises over the
next couple of years
and the match of the 401K but the word
George in this question that's got her
and other people they kind of get stuck
on this can I guess it yeah go for it
stability you nailed it they think well
it's a government job
so the government's always going to be
here
and there's no way they're going to lay
me off and that first of all that's just
not true so uh it's absolutely number
two take the full-time corporate job
with the higher salary opportunity to
get raises beyond that and the 401K with
a match of three percent you're going to
pay off that debt in no time here you've
got 30k in Consumer Debt if you take
this job for 100k that's 43 more than
the other job would have paid and you
said it's going to take you three years
making 100K you can pay off 30k in one
year and by the way you're still going
to be making forty three thousand
dollars more every single year that
corporate job probably with more upward
Mobility to make even more yes and let
me just say this I there listen
government work they're good people that
listen to this program watch this
program and you are in government work
but this idea that it's so much more
stable is a complete myth and you just
don't have the opportunity for growth
that I know uh so anyway uh good stuff
there all right George uh speaking of uh
the government
oh yeah big news in the news the last uh
24 48 hours all the rage among the youth
in Congress well no this is well I don't
know that you can refer to Joe Biden as
youth God bless his soul uh but uh Joe
Biden and Kevin McCarthy the president
and the Speaker of the House are just
locked in a battle I haven't been able
to see what's going on the last couple
hours but uh the uh the potential
government shutdown Janet Yellen
treasury secretary by the way I'm doing
this all from yesterday's news no
talking points here so I hope this is
accurate uh to the moment but uh uh
emergency measures by Janet Yellen to
avoid a government shutdown and this is
all over raising the debt ceiling Biden
and the Democrats want to raise the debt
ceiling and McCarthy and Republicans
don't want to do it uh we're not going
to talk about the politics of it or what
does it mean before it could be affected
if that happens is that something that
we just kind of don't feel George how
will raising the debt limit which is at
all-time highs how will that affect
those that are listening and watching
well the this is the idea if the U.S
defaulted on its debts meaning it can't
pay the carried interest that could
cause chaos now it's never happened and
so the idea here doesn't mean it won't
it doesn't mean it won't uh the the
chances of them raising the debt ceiling
probably pretty high because they keep
doing it every year they just keep
raising the credit limit even though
this is a showdown this is a negotiation
absolutely so if you're confused as to
what this all amounts to the debt
ceiling is the amount the U.S government
can borrow to honor its spending
obligations and uh here's how it affects
you so by the way the debt ceiling limit
uh was 31.4 trillion and we reached it
so you know Reach for the Stars can we
at least we hit a goal there that's sad
and so here's the the few ways you could
be impacted America by the debt ceiling
crisis number one is the stock market
the stock market does not like
uncertainty and defaulting on our debts
would cause the stock market to plunge
estimates uh Chief Economist Mark Zandy
said could plunge by one-third and erase
15 trillion in household wealth yeah
that hurt that's scary that could affect
a lot of people affect a lot of your
retirement savings we do not like that
the other thing it could affect is the
costs to borrow and so a default would
push interest rates even higher so the
cost to borrow homes to get that car
loan your credit card interest rates it
would explode it would cause Mayhem the
Silver Lining there is I hope it's it
stops people from borrowing more money
so there you go uh the last thing it
could affect is Social Security and
Medicare so the debt limit fight poses
several risks to these seniors who are
on Social Security Medicare
and so without a breakthrough in
Congress the government might not be
able to send out those monthly benefit
checks or pay for Medicare so and let's
not forget the overall value of the
dollar
that's true the dollar has been stronger
the value it's already dropped pretty
precipitously over the last couple days
and that again affects overall inflation
and it'll hurt GDP it'll hurt our
standing globally it's a it's a complete
mess and um and I'm just going to put
this out there we're gonna get back to
the phones and and it could because you
the people have the power
to get these bums attention in DC
because your governor
in Most states they have to balance the
budget many states
it's a constitutional requirement
for the state to budget but excuse me to
balance
its spreadsheet I get so angry talking
about it I can't talk well you know we
don't have a balanced budget amendment
to the U.S Constitution and you know Ken
we're around here we're very fiscally
conservative and uh Congress
historically would you love to see Dave
Ramsey go to Washington for about 30
days lock all of them in a room they
only get bathroom breaks and and food
breaks I would pay to watch that on
C-Span and David takes his Dave takes
his just his good old-fashioned budget
the old kitchen table sits in the middle
room yellow pad and he just starts going
through it and he would absolutely
balance the budget I believe it I know
he would I'm not kidding you I mean he
really could Dave darken the doors no of
that building that's the question no no
I don't think he has any interest he
wouldn't last 30 minutes up there much
less 30 days that it would take but uh
there you go all right to the phones we
go Devin joins us in Independence well
that's appropriate Independence Kansas
Devin how can we help
hi I'm doing great how are you guys
doing today we're having a blast what's
going on
opportunity
in my divorce I went through how much
um and I have about collectively about
16 000 left out of 42. okay
and what what is what is the 16k in debt
made up of
uh a car repossession that she let go
back and a credit card that she had all
right all right so what's your question
um so I currently work at a ranch right
now as a welder fabricator and a ranch
hand managing livestock I make about 45
a year and I just got a job opportunity
to go into the oil industry as a
um floor hand for a rig
what would that be pretty much going
from 45 about 40 to 45 a year here
whereas if I take that job I'll be
making about 96 to 110 all right so what
are you wondering you you dialed the
number because you're wondering
something
taking it
uh I'm a single father I have fulfilled
custody of my daughter and the job would
be more of on the road I'd be gone for
two weeks home for two weeks oh do you
have any support to help out with her
yes I do I have my fiance and my family
I'm doing it for a season it may only be
for a year but it'll put you in a
totally different financial position
could you make an extra 50k George is
absolutely right because you get the
fiance and parents to help with her your
heart's gonna be sad but you're going to
be debt free before you know it and then
you get rid of that job the minute you
get where you want to be I'd go baby
step two and three before I move on fill
up that emergency fund and then come
back home thanks for the call
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
I'm joined by my colleague George
Campbell that's with a K by the way
thank you and uh yeah absolutely and we
are here for you the phone number to
jump in is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
George uh it's it's I always love theme
hours uh big fan of here on the Big Show
and uh we've got a theme hour coming up
that's right so uh Dave Ramsey and
myself will be hosting an entree
leadership theme hour and if you don't
know what Entre leadership is it's
really Dave's teaching on business and
Leadership how he built this place from
a card table in his living room to the
Empire we see today there's the
best-selling book Entre leadership that
he wrote uh a decade ago and there's
also the podcast that I've been hosting
for the last year and a half and we love
helping small business owners out there
so if you have a business or leadership
question please email ask Ramsay
solutions.com and put entree leadership
in the subject line and our team will
get in touch with you to schedule a call
so that you can chat with Dave Ramsey
and myself very soon that is ask
ramseysolutions.com put entree
leadership in the subject line and we'll
talk business and Leadership all right
there it is Denver Colorado is where
Katie is hanging out Katie how can we
help
hi
um so my question
my husband and I are on step two and I
am confused as how to approach that step
if our budget is already using every
cent
okay so you are you using every dollar
or a different method yes no we use
every dollar we just signed up for the
financial peace course through our
church oh awesome and um we already had
a flight savings so we bypassed step one
okay
um so when you say you're now your
income is allocated it's every Dollar's
got a job we love that are you do you
have your minimum payments for each debt
listed in your budget
yes okay and so we're going to look at
that smallest debt we have what's that
balance on that smallest debt
sixteen hundred and what is it
um it's a credit card okay and so you're
saying there is zero dollars extra to
put onto that
payment
as of right now we did our first budget
meeting this past weekend and yeah okay
so there's nothing that you can cut
um
I mean I don't know that was a trick
question I wasn't I wasn't trying to be
tricky so Katie what you're really
saying is there's no margin to attack
this smallest debt and so we're going to
create that margin in your budget you're
not going to magically find it and the
way you do that is two ways you spend
less or you make more and I suggest you
do both so what is your take-home pay
that you're using in the budget
so I um own my own business I just
started a couple years ago I gave myself
a salary of 4 800 a month okay and then
my husband
um brings home 1800 every two weeks
okay so what does he do
he works on the he's like a mechanic for
the big massage chairs
the ones in the mall
uh yeah
wow fascinating all right he first of
all let me just I know Jordan I'm
jumping in and George's gonna walk you
can on a rant about massage chairs now
well first of all good on you for paying
yourself 4 800 bucks a month on a
business you just started let me just
let me first of all let me say way to go
thank you yeah um but uh he he needs to
be making more money you can tell him I
said that
so well if he can fix a big old massage
chair well I understand but if he can
fix a big old massage chair in the mall
there's a lot of things he can fix and
he needs to get after it do you
understand what I'm saying yeah like
right now yeah I think he went from a
high pressure job and gone 17 days a
month to now he's home
so we've kind of made compromises for
that and when I started my business two
years ago it's just taken off
so I I understand I understand I'm going
to give it back to George to walk you
through the budget but the big part of
this is he needs to be making money
okay he needs to be making more money
you don't have to I understand that he
went from a stressful I'm traveling so I
don't want to in any way minimize that
but there's a happy meeting and he's
only bringing home eighteen hundred
dollars every two weeks every two weeks
okay but still as a mechanic he's gonna
be making way more money than that
fixing stuff I'm just telling you so one
of the things that will help you guys is
if he's doubling his income at least
attempting to by what are all the things
he can fix what are the skills and
experience he brings to the table and I
just want to make sure you catch that
because it's going to make what George
is about to tell you a whole lot easier
do you understand
yeah yeah I mean he went from the Marine
Corps to to the oil field so that's
really all he's done his whole life so
he's got plenty of skills he's very
smart I know he is that's why I'm
believing in it yeah all right all right
so Katie you let's say you're taking
home 8 400 and what's your income side
of your budget look like
I'm sorry my income or the the income in
your every dollar budget what does it
reflect total for both of you for the
month
um 8400 that's what I had okay so you're
telling me right now there's eighty four
hundred dollars in expenses going out
yes
how is that possible
you've got a mortgage
um yes what's the mortgage
it's 1974 a month
okay
now there's still
65 400 left where is all that going
um so like the main ones are our
mortgage our utilities are 680. then
um we have three children so I allocate
150 per child for their activities
school lunches everything they need
um then we have one car payment because
one's paid off at 600 a month
and what's the car worth okay
uh I have no idea I've never Kelly Blue
booked we've had it for three years it's
a 2017 Dodge Ram it's a pickup do you
need the pickup right now
um my husband thinks he does oh thanks
well I'm wondering if you if you can
sell it for more than it's worth and
clean up this debt that would help this
process and help you clear 600 worth of
margin to start these uh this debt
snowball what what other debt do you
have
um student loans in the car and that
credit card that's
right what what is the consumer on the
debt
um so that was one of my questions it's
56 000 total okay but then I have
business debt and I didn't know if that
should be included or because I keep my
business separate is at a separate
entity your name's on all those
documents isn't it
yes so that's personal debt so we're
going to roll all of that into the debt
snowball smallest to largest ignore the
interest rates attack the little one
with a Vengeance and right now you need
to create that margin and so that means
he's working more you're working more
and go through the budget do a budget
audit go through every single line item
even your insurance premiums and go
let's go shop around for the insurance
premiums and we're not eating out right
now while we're doing that so we're
grocery shopping we might switch grocery
stores buy the generic brands start to
look at every single item and go how can
I get this down by twenty percent thirty
percent fifty percent to create a few
extra 100 bucks to throw the debt
okay so then I guess my next question is
where is the balance because I only work
four days a week okay because I want to
when I make good money doing it
um but then if I work an extra day I
could bring home another 1800 a month
heck yes and I don't have time with my
children oh for heaven's sakes do they
know that's not true that is not well
what do they do in the days you're
working are they at school
two of them are so I have a 14 year old
12 year old and a four-year-old first of
all on the days that I'm home first of
all your 14 year old 12 year old don't
want to be around you as much as you
think they do trust me I got three
teenagers come on yeah yeah it has
nothing to do with you that's just
called they're just weird humans at that
age
um so that's one thing secondly I
appreciate what you're saying but this
is for a season number one number two
you said if I work another day I don't
see them at all that's not good math you
know that's not true you will see them
yeah I mean most parents are working
five days a week 40 hours a week anyways
with commutes and so I don't I don't see
this as you being away from your kids uh
much more than the average person and
it's worth it because if you do that
that cuts down your debt free time now
it's down by six months okay so once you
start doing the debt snowball calculator
you're gonna get addicted you're gonna
get excited you need to get your husband
on board with this to where he's going
let's sell the truck honey we can be
debt free six months faster if I sell
the truck let's go and then you're
hanging out with the kids way more
because you've got time you've got
options you've got freedom you've got
margin that's the goal with this plan
yeah it's doable
only if you two come together and go
let's get after it for a short season
super intense on the other side of it
life is peaceful it's better than it's
ever been before thank you for the call
don't move more of your calls right
around the corner this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back America to the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman George Campbell joins me
this hour the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our scripture of the day comes from
Colossians 4 2 devote yourselves to
prayer keeping Alert in it with an
attitude of Thanksgiving our quote is
from Tony Dungy even though we can't
always choose our circumstances we can
always choose our attitude in the
circumstances
uh though this weekend in the Ramsey
newsletter we've got an article about
how uh marketing offers and one time
deals could be money traps well that
feels like George Campbell inspired
right up there uh while these brick
promotions may sound like a good way to
save money in the moment the word free
is very tempting it's most likely a
money trap say it's not so George oh
it's soaking
some money traps may be more obvious
than others like timeshares but some
traps may be a bit more sneaky like no
money down plants listen we've all been
stupid with money which is why we've
listed 10 money traps for you to avoid
in this weekend's edition of the Ramsey
newsletter simply sign up at
ramseysolutions.com
newsletter to subscribe to our Sunday
newsletter to get the full list that is
ramseysolutions.com newsletter it's like
getting the Sunday paper but it's free
and in your inbox George did you ever
did your dad ever get the Sunday paper
oh yeah we said I'd sit there I'd go
through the catalogs I'd print out
coupons it was a joy yeah I will tell
you that it was only about six or seven
years ago that I finally got rid of my
Sunday night I could see it in the
bathrobe pulling out the old paper you
know really enjoyed it really enjoyed
all the sections really enjoyed it and I
used to get the USA Today delivered to
my driveway and I would uh slink out in
the uh in the full body length row we
don't want to offend any neighbors and
grab it it had all four sections yeah
you can't show off those chicken legs
too early
it's a bit much for anybody to handle so
uh but anyway missed that yeah when did
it just become not a thing anymore I
don't know they're still paper boys
doing their routes at 4am I don't even
know if there's still a Sunday paper
it still exists I got some research to
do Megan joins us in Tallahassee Florida
Megan how can we help
hey y'all hey hey what's up
so my question is I am currently in what
I thought was my dream job and whenever
I was going to school for it I loved it
I was excelling all that good stuff I
graduated 4.0 GPA
um so anyway I'm in the job right now
I've had it for about six seven months
and I just feel like I'm kind of going
through the motions now and making like
mistakes in my job that I shouldn't be
and just kind of feeling like is this
the job that I should have and then on
top of that like the company I work for
a hospital and it just feels like
they're more about about the you know
getting money
then like patient care well that's
probably true sadly what is the job what
is the dream job
a certified medical coder and so this is
what you want to went to school for you
enjoyed learning and getting qualified
for it and for a season you really
enjoyed it
yes
but you've only been doing it six or
seven months so I'm just and I'm not
trying to pick at you I'm just truly
curious at what point did it become yuck
and suck instead of yay
um I feel like
maybe like two or three months ago
whenever I kept like being like Oh yes I
can take on more work I'll take on more
work I can do it aha
so yes now we figured it out
Megan you still enjoy the work
but too much of any one thing is awful
if I ate steak every day three times a
day wouldn't take long for me to hate
steak am I right yes all right so you
have not
created a boundary for yourself in your
desire to please you're also brand new
or out of college you've been in the job
for just a few months and they keep
piling on and you keep saying yes I can
do it yes I can do it and now you're at
the point where you're going Kim I can't
do it anymore
so all right great so here's the point I
wanted to get clear and you get clear on
what's really going on you don't all of
a sudden hate the dream job you aren't
all of a sudden missing details because
you just don't have it anymore you're
overwhelmed sweetheart
okay am I right
yes heavy I mean listen it's literally
like trying to get a drink from a fire
hydrant when a fireman opens that thing
up and that water is just streaming out
you're not getting a sip of water it's
just too much try not to drown right
yes okay so here's what we have to do
you're gonna have to do what very few
people have the courage to do
and that is go to your leader and go hey
I said yes I can do it
and I said yes I can do it too many
times and I went to school for this I
love this work but this is on me I said
yes that I can do it and I took off too
much I in order in other words I went to
the buffet and I got too much food on
the plate and I can't eat it I can't do
it I need your help
okay how does that sound
yes I definitely need to do that now
come up with a solution
so when you go back to them you have to
say I took on this much more work and
you know what that is I don't and you
got to say I need to cut back on this
much like I I said yes here here and
here and I shouldn't have so I need to
make sure we give this work to somebody
else because I want to keep doing this I
want to do a good job and they need you
you got it
yes you got it but hey do not be
confused this is not go get a new job
because all of a sudden I don't like
medical coding this is you took on way
too much and you're drowning and we need
to make sure that we can uh get our head
above water then the the enjoyment the
love of the work will come back
all right let's go to Bozeman Montana
Jeff is there Jeff how can we help
guys thanks for taking my call um I'm
just calling today uh
I'm kind of recently new to the Ramsey
method and me and my wife have been
working on it the last few months but
just recently her dad gave us the
opportunity where he wants us to buy his
business which is where I currently work
and she thinks that we need to wait
longer and pay off some more debt before
we do it I'm kind of hesitant and just
kind of want to go for it uh we he said
he will finance us himself and we'd be
able to just pay him off the profits
that the business makes
um so it wouldn't really be cutting into
our current income at all and it is a
pretty successful uh business
so where's her hesitation coming from
obviously she wants to pay off the debt
you're saying it's not going to affect
your debt payoff goals
uh so part of her hesitation she doesn't
want us to be stuck with the business
and also we're expecting a baby this
summer
the big life change
now how how quickly is this would this
takeover happen if you're paying him
from the profits are you Owners Day One
how does that piece work
yeah we would basically we would be
owners day one and we would pay him for
probably like 12 years are you guys
ready to take on ownership and that
responsibility I'm guessing it's more
time involved as well uh I'm already uh
running the business and I just got
promoted in the last couple months
so it would be a little bit more but not
a whole lot I'm already pretty much the
the head person in charge there what's
the structure of the deal how much is it
going to cost you guys and how long will
this take
uh it will take yeah about 12 years to
pay off and it's like a five million
dollar business so
um so what's he charging you to take it
he wouldn't be charging us any interest
and so it's like
um like four or five hundred thousand
dollars a year
wow so what happens you know a few years
from now let's say the profits aren't
there and you still owe him millions of
dollars
right and so that is a possibility he
has ran this business for 30 years so it
is pretty consistent but I mean anything
can happen
um so that is a possibility what's the
rush on doing this now can it be a year
from now you start this process uh uh I
mean he's kind of rushing us and then I
also I'm just like well I mean the
sooner we start the sooner we start you
know
a savings account basically you know all
the money that we pay into that business
theoretically once we own it and are
able to sell it that would be you know
just more money that we would have I
mean it sounds like it could be a good
deal but I'm worried with your pregnant
wife stressing out about this and having
the debt if it's just we need to pause
and look into it more and get more in
writing what do you think Ken I think
that he wants you all to have the
business and I think it's okay for you
to go you know what can we just push
this off a year and then I'm all in uh I
think George's advice is right and I
think he'll be fine he's not gonna force
you to do this now so just be a man
he'll be cool hey George good hour
always fun good show I want to thank
James and the crew behind the glass for
keeping us on the air I want to thank
you America this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]